hello there today we're going to look at
decision transformer
reinforcement learning via sequence
modeling
by lily chen kevin liu and others of uc
berkeley
facebook ai research and google brain
on high level this paper ditches pretty
much
anything and everything of reinforcement
learning in an
offline rl setting and substitutes it
for
simple sequence modeling using
transformers of course and
through that they're able to achieve
some pretty compelling
results in the things they test at least
they're able to
keep up and be on par with the current
best frameworks for doing offline
reinforcement learning
so we're going to look at this paper and
what it what it does in in terms of
sequence modeling
and how this looks the key ingredient
here
besides the transformer is going to be
the fact that we are
instead of maximizing the reward we're
going to condition
on the desired reward and uh through
that
we we can sort of influence what the
model is going to do in the future this
allows more effective
offline reinforcement learning and makes
the offline rl problem pretty
straightforward into
a sequence modeling problem i do have
a little bit of troubles with the paper
in various aspects but i'm sure
we'll come to that but i'm just warning
you this might be a bit of a rant
mixed with explaining the paper though
the paper is is pretty cool so don't get
me wrong on that
that being said there is concurrent work
also out of berkeley as i understand it
um where it's this is called the third
trajectory transformer reinforcement
learning is one big sequence modeling
problem
that uses the sequence modeling in a bit
of a different way so what they do is
they use it as sort of a world model
and then they use beam search in order
to
in in order to find good trajectories in
that
so it's a little bit of a different
approach and i
just from skimming this paper right here
i think
i this one might be a bit more of a
of an approach that i would subscribe to
um
but i guess we'll see what happens going
forward
and oh wait why did this show up
reinforcement learning upside down by
schmidt uber
ah this must just have gotten in here by
accident sorry
um let's go back to this paper they say
we introduce a framework that abstracts
reinforcement
learning as a sequence modeling problem
this allows us to draw upon the
simplicity and scalability of the
transformer architecture and associated
advances
in language modeling such as the gpt
line and bird
in particular we present the decision
transformer an architecture that casts
the problem of
rl as conditional sequence modeling
unlike prior approaches that
fit fit value functions or compute
policy gradients
decision transformers simply outputs the
optimal actions by leveraging
a causally masked transformer okay so as
i said
they ditch things like uh policy
gradients
or value functions none of that
we're simply going to do sequence
modeling right here
by conditioning on an autoregressive
model on the desired
return past states and actions our
decision transformer model can get
can generate future action that achieve
the desired return so a key concept
here is going to be this desired return
thing
and here as well so there are multiple
ingredients to this paper there's a lot
to to unpack
right here and lastly they say it
achieves
it matches or exceeds the performance of
state-of-the-art model-free offline rl
baselines
again this is sort of zooming down into
a problem so
we are in the world of model-free and
offline reinforcement learning
algorithms there is as i said there's a
lot to
unpack here so first of all what is
offline reinforcement learning this is
contrasted to online reinforcement
learning
online reinforcement learning is where
you have an agent
and an environment and the agent sort of
gets to perform
actions in the environment and the
environment responds with a reward
and a state or the not really a state
but an
observation but we sometimes it is
the state uh if it's not a partially
observable
environment so the agent actively gets
to interact with the environment to try
out things and its goal is going to be
to maximize that reward in
offline reinforcement learning it's a
different
situation so in offline reinforcement
learning
you are your agent is here and what you
get is not an environment but what you
get
is a data set and this data set
will contain it will contain lots
of experience from other
agents so you would simply get to
observe
what a different agent has done and so
there's going to be a lot of like
episodes in here so what happened in the
past to this other agent
and purely by observing that other agent
you somehow have to
learn a good policy to achieve a good
reward
this is different because you cannot go
out and sort of test your hypotheses in
this world
you cannot have a good idea and say well
i'm gonna try that
you can't do sort of targeted
exploration and so on you simply get to
look at a bunch of trajectories
and then uh decide what you want to do
so we need a bunch of different
approaches here
and and uh one that they compare to
is so there are two that mainly that
they compare to
one is called they call it bc which is
behavior cloning
where what you're trying to do is you
simply try to mimic
the agent uh that you observe in the
events
where it has led to two good rewards
right so that's how you maximize the
reward you simply say well
that agent there it got a good reward uh
so i'm just gonna try to sort of clone
that behaviors as
behavior cloning from the name i'm i'm
butchering the explanation but roughly
that's what it's supposed to do the
other approach is you view this
as a let's say more a traditional
reinforcement learning problem where you
do
q learning so in queue learning um
what you do is you are in a state and
you have maybe like three actions at
your disposal
and every time you again have three
actions at your disposal
so you get this sort of tree that you
could
do so you're in the first state and what
you want is you want to ask your q
function uh how much how much is
how much is this worth maybe the q
function says five how much is this
worth
six and how much is this worth for so
the q function is supposed to tell you
if
you um take this action and after that
action you follow
the the policy like
after that action you again do ask the q
function
for the q value which
what's the total reward you're going to
get q learning is
very very classic reinforcement learning
algorithm and you can actually
do q learning from a data set like this
it doesn't need to be
you yourself that makes the experience
that's the thing about q learning is
that it can be done from offline data
other than policy gradients uh you need
sort of a you need a correction um if
you do policy gradients and it usually
doesn't work if it's complete
offline i it might work i'm not super
informed
like this but q learning is possible
from offline data
and apparently the current currently
good baseline is
conservative q learning um which you're
going to see in this paper
which uh fixes the
the um the bug let's say the tendency
for for these q functions in the offline
setting
to overestimate the q value so
apparently
uh they they tend to overestimate the
value
that you get from certain actions
conservative q learning
uh is a more like a pessimistic approach
so these are the two baselines that
we're going to compare to you'll notice
behavior cloning some kind of relation
to inverse reinforcement learning
not really or um yeah so so that's
one approach q learning uh is also an
approach
here we're just going to do sequence
modeling so what does this
mean and the key concept as i said is
going to be the condition on that reward
uh sorry so so this was offline rl
now there are people have pointed out
problems with
the approach here uh which some of those
problems are simply problems of offline
reinforcement learning
so for example which data set do you use
right here
turns out in their experiments they use
a benchmark data set
which is the the data set where this
agent right here
is a dqn learner so an active
reinforcement learner
so naturally you're going to get out
like some some good
episodes out of that so it's more like
learning from expert demonstration
rather than from random random
demonstrations
okay so it's crucially important which
data set
you use but that's that's a fault of
offline rl
of the setting itself rather than of
this particular algorithm so i just want
to
want to point that out but keep in mind
the data set they're using for their
main experiments
is one of let's say a rather high
performing agent
in this world okay so so
that's that so the second thing right
here is their
their use of the of a transformer
now is the use of a transformer
crucial to this algorithm and the answer
is is no
so whenever the transformer comes to
mind
this can be any sequence modeling
algorithm right here
transformers are trendy okay but this
can be an lstm that does autoregressive
sequence modeling anything that does
sort of autoregressive sequence modeling
is going to be good for
this task right here the the core here
is going to be this is a
sequence model it's not an rl
model in fact transformers for rl have
been
a thing you know usually what people do
is they use lstms as a backbone for
reinforcement learning algorithms
using transformers has several
advantages in offline
and or online reinforcement learning
algorithms so usually you have some sort
of a state
right here so you have your history with
states and actions and rewards
and so on and an lstm will take
in that state and and action
well let's just let's do it something
like this so you have
state action reward state
action reward state action reward
whatever you did in the past right so an
lstm will take that in
and it will propagate its hidden state
through times
i realize some of you youngsters might
not actually know what an lstm is this
is a recurrent neural network
that processes one time step at a time
and then here
at the end you're supposed to output
whatever the next action is going to be
right you have your history of actions
you're supposed to output
whatever the next action is going to be
and you're going to get back
a state and a reward along with it and
then you
incorporate that right here into the
next action
so if you train this thing in any way
let's say q learning policy gradient
what not
if it's a q learning you're not going to
output an action directly you're going
to output q values
that's a minor modification to the a
what you have to do is you have to and
that's the difficulty in reinforcement
learning in general
you have to somehow make a connection
between the rewards
you get from this let's say this action
gets you a reward
the reward you get from the action to
some something that you you predicted so
you predicted several you predicted an
action here and an action here right
these are
these actions now just because you got a
reward from this action it doesn't
actually mean that this action was
the smart action or the good action
right if you
are in a chess game it's not the actual
last
move that is the good move even though
that move gets you the
all the reward the cur the crucial move
might have happened
20 moves before so the the
underlying reinforcement learning
problem is to assign that reward
to which action was actually the smart
action
such that in the future you can take
that more so maybe
this action right here was the smart
action so you need a way
to figure out that that was the smart
action and
you know back propagation over time will
do this but in an lstm
you can see right here you need to back
propagate you know through
one two maybe three
different uh computation steps in order
to reach there
and now this is three steps but think if
the good action was 50 steps ago or 500
steps ago
this quickly gets um gets tricky
normally we can unroll lstms like this
for
maybe i don't even know like like
not more than a couple of dozen steps
right so
it gets tricky so what people do is they
use
what's called dynamic programming and
that is a thing that
here with the sequence modeling approach
we're going to ditch
and this this is uh
one of the fundamental things so instead
of having to just learn from the reward
and assign it to an action
what you're going to do is you're also
going to along with the actions right
here you're going to
output a value and the value tells you
sort of how good you are doing
now q function in a way is already a
value so if you're doing q learning
you're doing this
automatically and then the way you
learn this is called temporal difference
learning so you know
let's say this is the this here is the
final stage of the game
okay so you always get a reward here
it's maybe plus one here it's minus five
and so on okay now instead of back
propagating
only that reward back what you're going
to do is at every
step you want to predict a value
obviously the last value is going to be
equal to the reward itself
but here your value
is sort of your expected reward in the
future if you take
you know the good actions that you're
going to take so
here your value might be maybe negative
4.5 because you know you're
actually though you're probably going to
take the action that gives you a good
reward right so
it's maybe like plus 0.9 because you're
fairly sure you're going to take that
good action
and then down here it's
maybe so you get five reward from going
there
um no wait that's the q value i said
that's the q value
so here your value is going to be
something like plus
point seven um
so it doesn't really matter what the
numbers are what matters
is that now you're not you're learning
signal
doesn't just come from the uh
from the reward itself
your learning signal is you're from here
you're trying to predict
the reward but you're also trying to
predict the output of your own function
like one or two or three steps into the
future
so if you've done an episode and at the
end you got a reward
right here you could your value function
right here
could try to just output that reward but
that's really noisy
so what you're doing is you're saying
well you know
i have predicted a value here and here
and here and here
and here so why aren't i
training my value function to also
predict these things and
by predict i basically mean so if
if i was in this value and this
transition got me like a reward
of something then this value here
should equal to this minus this reward
because
you know like that's that's how the
value is supposed to function
so you're trying to predict the output
of your own value function this also
works with the q function this is the
famous
bellman recurrence relation where the q
function of a state is equal to the
reward you get from performing an action
according to the policy in that state
plus
the q function at the state that you're
reaching
so again with the same policy
and the the r here is drawn
from the action that the policy gives
you
something like this so the r is the
result of performing the action
okay so this f this fundamental relation
is the basis of q learning and you can
do
as i said right here this is called
temporal difference learning
so what they call td all of this is
based on
concepts of dynamic programming
we all ditch this here and so it is
important to go through
so that you understand what we're not
doing okay
why do we need all of this why do we
need the q functions and the temporal
difference learning and so on
well because it's really hard to do that
credit assignment over long stretches
of time now
in we can see that this is the case with
an lstm right especially if we can't
back propagate
all the way through the lstm in a
transformer
what does a transformer do you have a
sequence what does a transformer do
it uses attention in order to look at
a sequence at a hole right it through
the attention mechanism
it can route information from any
sequence element
to any other sequence element in a
single step
so essentially it technically could do
this credit assignment right here in a
single step
if and that's a big if if anything
fits into its context okay
and that's i think one of the crucial
criticisms of this paper right here
in that as as as far as
no i don't think all it fits in all into
the context
but you can see that there's a trade-off
right you're able to do the assignment
in one step
okay but as soon as you would like to
predict correlations and do credit
assignment across
longer spans than the context you
need to resort back to something like
the dynamic programming approaches right
here which they say
they can ditch now they don't only say
that because their
context is long but that is when they
say
how the transformer benefits this
instead of like an lstm or something
like this
this is the reason that you can do this
credit assignment in one step across the
context
however always think that statement has
an if
if the credit assignment needs to happen
longer than one context like if the
relevant action for the reward
is more away the transformers out of
luck because it doesn't fit into the
context
and we would need to go back to
something like this
but there is a second reason of course
and that is the
sequence modeling approach and that is
something i
i i see at the core of this a little bit
so the the causal transformer you know
cool it's a transformer
okay we could use any other sequence
modeling approach
now viewing rl as a sequence modeling
problem
is a different thing so what does this
thing do
so instead of having a neural network
that you know here is here's the history
okay this is the history this is the
rewards you got in the past and
disregard the little hat on the r it's
the states of the past
it's the actions of the past actually
extends into the past okay
so this is the input you get and you
would get that in any other
reinforcement learning algorithm
what you would get to is this thing
right here the current
state right and this goes through a
little encoder they use the dqn encoder
so this is a little convolutional neural
network
right that encodes the state so it's
technically able to handle
uh very complex states and so on by
simply encoding them
into a latent space
um so there's no attention on the like
on in the state space right here the
attention really happens over the
over the sequence now from this
right the classic rl algorithms they
wouldn't have this from this they would
try to predict an
action that maximizes the future reward
what this does differently is
they say well instead of giving me an
action that maximizes the future reward
i want to
i want to tell the system what reward i
would like
and then it's not giving me an action to
maximize the reward
it is actually supposed to give me an
action that achieves
exactly the reward that i have uh
presented
okay so i ask it for a reward and it
gives me the action that corresponds to
achieving that reward in the future
this is is different right and i can
still do
uh reward maximization by simply putting
a high number there right i want to get
a lot of reward and like 21 is the
maximum
in pong which this game is right here
so you can say i want to achieve 21
reward please
give me an action that achieves 21
reward and that will be corresponding to
getting as much reward as possible
notice that you do
need to know the maximum reward um
it doesn't actually work if you just
would put 1 billion billion billion
as we will like as the their experiments
kind of
indicate so that's a drawback of this
now uh just when i go
back to this paper that slipped in just
by accident i have this open
right here by schmidt uber
don't predict rewards it says just map
them to actions
so they say we transform reinforcement
learning into a form of
supervised learning okay which
sounds like you know offline rl by
turning rl on its head
and did uh you look at this the memes
are strong in this one
okay upside down rl i've actually made a
video on upside down
rl they say or standard
rl predicts rewards while
whatever this is instead uses rewards
as task defining inputs together with
representations of time horizon and
other computable functions of historic
and desired
future data uh r l
later learns to interpret these input
observations as commands
mapping them to actions um
through supervised learning on past
possibly accidental
experience okay so uh
this it is actually i of course this
isn't by accident so
i knew this paper right here and when i
read this paper
it immediately uh sprung into my mind
and
schmidt uber also i as i see it wasn't
the entirely first
who did anything like this like we've
known about goal conditioned
reinforcement learning for a while and
so on
so this is not necessarily a new idea
they do reference schmidt huber's paper
very briefly
in in this paper uh staying stating that
it's kind of a markovian approach and
and so on
even though here you have markovian
interfaces and here you have
non-markovian partially observable
interfaces
and the advantages that schmidt hoover
names right here
are very much the same for example they
continuously say they don't need
discount factors
and here also you have no problems with
discount factors and so on
so i i wanted to point this out and i
wanted to point out that
the paper is referenced in this paper
but essentially here you have the three
components the component is offline rl
plus a transformer plus
viewing the problem as a sequence
modeling problem by
conditioning on the reward
so why does this make sense to condition
under on the future desired reward
well it makes sense first of all
because in classic reinforcement
learning why don't we do that
why don't we we say i want to get this
reward please give me the action to
it because it's a lot more work
right if i just want to maximize my
reward i need a function
right i need a neural network here is my
state here is my neural network maybe
it's a policy gradient method
give me an action and that action is
supposed to maximize the reward
so now i need an additional input the
desired reward
and also give me an action now the
network doesn't only need to remember
what do i need to do to
perform well it needs to be able to
distinguish what do i need to do to
perform well what do i need to do to
perform
a little bit worse what do i need to do
to perform
terribly it's a lot more stuff to
remember for
the network the hope of course is that
with all the the advances we've seen in
sequence modeling
um that essentially these transformers
are
capable of of memorizing or
learning all of those different things
we we know that transformers
are almost unlimited in their capacity
to absorb
data and learn stuff so the hope is that
uh these models will be capable of
learning that thing
the neck at doing this though
is this is a technique
that naturally maps to offline
reinforcement learning
so offline reinforcement learning in
general is a harder task than online
reinforcement learning right for the
reasons i
outlined however this particular thing
lends itself extremely well to the task
of offline reinforcement
learning so what do i mean if you have a
history
you take one history from here
and it says well i was in this state i
performed this action i got this reward
i was in this state and then i came to
this state i performed this action
i got this reward and so on okay
what you can try to do and what q
learning tries to do
is it tries to somehow learn the the q
function
that takes state and action condition on
the history
and sort of uh predict the future
rewards and so on so it tries to figure
out what it needed to do
instead of doing what this agent did in
order to achieve
higher rewards so it is sort of
trying to look at the agent that it sees
critically
and be like you probably didn't do
something well there but it has no way
to act in the world it has no way to
to go out and try it itself instead this
thing it simply accepts it's like
it accepts the history it simply says oh
well you did these things
and you got this reward okay cool um
and if you know anything about these
sequence models and transformers that
they can
memorize stuff quite well so
going forward maybe think of these what
these
transformers do as simply memorizing the
the training data set okay i know it's
not the case but
you memorize the training data set well
now if
you memorize the training data set and
you're in this
situation right here you see a history
you see a state and the sort of
the human tells you i would like to get
21 reward
what the transformer can do is it can
simply say okay
let me go into my training data set let
me
find some let me find some
uh sequence where the agent
was in the same kind of history also was
in this state
and also ended up getting about 21
reward
out of the future actions now what did
that agent do
well it did this action okay it and it's
reasonable to assume
that you know if you're in the same kind
of history
and uh if you want the same reward as
that agent got you should probably act
the same as that agent
did okay it is a lot like behavior
cloning
though behavior cloning still focuses on
sort of getting high reward as i under
understand it um so it it simply
takes what comes in as expert
demonstrations whereas here
you just you accept the history as it is
and if you're in a new situation you
the question to the sequence model is
essentially how
would a sequence that evolves like this
okay that evolves like this how would it
continue
in the training data set and
what it will give you it will give you
the action that agents who were in a
similar situation
and ended up getting that similar reward
that you want to get
those what did those agents do just do
the same thing
and you're probably going to end up in
the same place as they did
okay that's that's the approach right
here um
you can see how this is is useful right
though again it it
only given that we ditch all of the
rl um given that we ditch all of the url
mechanics right here which they claim as
a positive and
certainly it is a positive you don't
need to parse out what you needed to do
and so on you simply accept history and
say
okay i'm going to do the same kind of
things
instead of that if
so i just said i'm going to look at
agents
that had the same kind of history and
we're in the same kind of situation
now if you think about back about this
problem right here of the context length
what if the future reward right here
is crucially dependent on an action you
did back here
right you could have two agents that
have the exact same history as far as
the context reaches back
but done a different action back here
and the sequence model would have no
trouble uh sorry would have like no
chance of differentiating between the
two
it they look the same okay one agent
ended up with a really nice reward the
other agent
ended up with a really bad reward even
worse
the data set couldn't contain an agent
that
ended up in the bad reward but had you
done q learning you could
maybe figure it out from other
trajectories
so as much as they i feel as much as
they tout
the ability to ditch uh the whole
mecha like the whole machinery of
reinforcement learning right here
you run into the same problem like even
with this like all of this
it does not alleviate the problem if you
want to go beyond
how far you can backprop uh you need
to you need to use the dynamic
programming approaches
okay like i don't see a way around it
maybe i'm terribly
wrong but yeah so
the transformers are good for doing the
credit assignment over
the longer distances than the lstms um
yes certainly but that's valid for
online offline rl
and so on whether you do sequence
modeling or not
it doesn't alleviate the problem that
these approaches were trying to solve
in the first place though the sequence
modeling approach is different
and does bring like a different view on
the problem
and again you can do the sequence
modeling approach because
it there is hope that with these
transformers you can actually absorb
that much data
and learn from that so
that is sort of the thing we're in that
that was
actually already the the technique right
here we're not even past
the the first page and that
is that's already the thing you get this
data and they're like you can
deterministically you can see that right
you can deterministically
transform this into the format they want
so this
state action and desired future return
or future return you simply look into
the future which you can do because it's
a data set
and you sort of calculate what the the
future
reward is at this particular time step
so you can easily
generate that training data then you can
use classic sequence modeling
in order to do that their idea
of what happens is encapsulated again in
this
um in this thing right here
so this is a very very
example problem that they come up with
so they
consider a task up here
of finding the shortest path in a
on a directed graph which can be posed
as an rl
problem okay the reward
is zero when the agent is at the goal
node and negative one otherwise we train
gpt model to predict the next token in a
sequence of returns to go
which is the sum of future reward state
and actions training
only on random walk data with no expert
demonstrations
we can generate optimal trajectories at
test time
by adding a prior to generate the
highest possible
returns they also say see more details
and empirical
results in the appendix i've looked at
the appendix
nothing there i've looked at the code
nothing there uh
just adjusting i mean it is a toy
example to illustrate but
like there's nothing there of this
example
so what they do is they have a graph
there is a goal or you're supposed to
just find
the um the shortest path what you do is
you just do random walks okay
some of these random walks will actually
fail like this one here so
the all the rewards are negative
infinity um
some of them will succeed and then you
can
generate that training data okay so from
here that
all the future reward is negative four
from this particular
random walk you did here okay here you
start at a different location
also negative four because you're going
to take four steps
now what you do with this sequence
modeling approach
is you say i want to start from this
node
however however i would like
to get a reward of negative three
okay which is a lesser reward than you
got
um all the way here so what you're
asking the model to do
and by the way like i'm pretty sure
this should say negative two to make
their example compelling
okay but so i i think there's kind of a
flaw in this
toy example but i hope you can still see
what they're doing so you're saying i
would like to get
a very high reward or a low negative
reward i guess
a low magnitude negative reward going
from here which corresponds to finding a
really short path
right and what the model is going to do
is going to look at its training data
and says well
was i in a similar situation at some
point
like in the training data set and it's
if it's gonna find yes yes actually
here i was in a very much similar
situation
um and and so i wanted to get exac
actually exactly that reward i was in
that
situation the history is a bit different
but you know who cares
uh now i'm here as well and what did the
agent do
that then went on and reached exactly
the reward i want
well it did this action right here okay
i'll just
i'll just do that same action this is
just
comes out of the sequence model right so
it's the sequence model simply tells you
how would a sequence that started like
this continue and
it tells you the action and then it
looks at this thing right here
and here is a bit where it fails right
they say each step gets you negative one
reward so technically
at inference time at inference time what
you would do is you would look at
um here so you get negative one from
here
so here you will put negative two so at
the beginning you have to specify the
reward you wanna get
and from there on you can calculate sort
of the next reward
uh they need this to be negative one
right here actually because
um so let's just imagine that for some
reason you got a negative two here
right so they need this to be negative
one
because that makes their example so the
sequence model says well
was i in this situation at some point
and i got out i got a negative one yes i
was here and what did i do to achieve
that
i went there okay i'm gonna go there ah
now i'm at the goal okay and
technically you find somewhat the
shortest now this again
this doesn't the example here doesn't
work because you start with negative
three
you're going to end up with negative two
right here that wouldn't match the blue
one that would actually match this one
so you would not get the shortest path
so you should actually start out with an
oracle knowing that the shortest path is
negative two
um that would of course not match
any example you have in your training
data but the sequence model could say
well
this is kind of close to this right
so the most likely action is still going
to be the one
right here and then you take the one
right here and then you're in the
negative one
regime and then you match this one right
here
i hope you can see right how that that
figures out a bit so this
can also handle if you don't get the
expected reward
which of course can happen right it's
not everything is always deterministic
so because you reassess after every step
you reassess you ask
sort of your training data set and this
is very much how we think of these big
transformer language models what they do
is they sort of interpolate the training
data set so they stitch together
different pieces
of the training data set which is you
can see that
happening right here of course
you already saw the flaw you need to
know
what reward you would like to achieve
and um
so like by the way lottek is beautiful
isn't it uh maybe that's just my thing i
don't i don't recall that being
like this so by the way the code is
available and also the pseudo code
big props here you can see that the
decision transformer in blue
in atari lags a bit behind what they
call dd learning so this td learning
that's the
the converts conservative q learning and
the behavior cloning
which they term bc in the open
in the openai gym uh it outperforms it a
little bit
and then there's this key to door task
that we're going to get into
in just a bit so
um i just want to quickly mention that
their primary comparison here is this
cql uh and
they make a big deal about sort of not
needing
discount factors i'm not really sure
what they mean
there are usually two different discount
factors in these algorithms
so one of them is usually found right
here
in the objective formulation so
here they say what we want to do is
maximize the expected return
which is this quantity right here okay
so what you want to do is you maximize
your expected future returns in the
episode
now this is usually different some
people formulate it
as the expected um
return in the future
but discounted by a discount factor
that you raise to the power so you're
essentially saying the future rewards
are less valuable than current rewards
and that gives you some
sort of stability but it also gets you
short-sighted in a sense one
however this is a choice this is a
choice of the problem
formulation now i get people train
with this for maybe stability reasons
and then they still test
um and actually report the undiscounted
reward at the end
okay but i'm just saying this is a
choice and their choice right here
is different from what cql does so cql
explicitly
uh maximizes the discounted future
returns
while they maximize the future uh
i just want to point out that there is
an actual difference here the other
difference
is in the td learning okay so the
by the way if you don't do this if you
don't discount your returns
um you get the situation that
you can you can cycle so if you know if
you
if if you get like positive rewards or
zero rewards for certain transitions
it can just like if someone is losing
okay a game so here would be
negative one this is the only two
options um either lose
or you know go back here now chess has a
built-in protection against this
but other things you can just the agent
will just circle forever because
it doesn't cost anything and if it were
to go here it would actually lose
so you usually discount no actually
that's not why you discount
um sorry that that is a bad example
but there are good reasons to discount
future words here you would actually
implement some sort of a penalty like
minus 0.1 for
just any step you do um
yeah but discounting maybe you could you
could win if you could win
the agent could still go in circles
because well it can still win
later right um yeah in any case that's
one discount fact the other discount
factor is in the
td learning so right here um
and that's a different discount factor
you say well
i'm going to predict this next step
right here
uh that's probably a pretty accurate
description and that reward here is
quite a good signal
given that i am in in this step right
here the next one maybe
a bit more noisy right because it's two
steps ahead and then uh
i could you know i could be doing
different actions uh maybe the
transition is stochastic so
when i learn my value function from all
of these different goals
okay i'm going to value
this target as a learning objective
right here you have that recurrence
relation i'm going to value this target
the highest i'm going to value this one
a little bit less so
i'm more trying to match this oops sorry
i'm more trying to match um
this one right here given that reward
then i'm going to match
this one right here giving the given the
two rewards okay
both should be accurate so the value
should match this the
reward plus this one the value should
also match
these two rewards plus this one but the
second one is more unsure
so the td learning usually you have uh
classically called another discount
factor lambda
where you discount sort of future losses
and they say we don't need the discount
factor right here i don't know which one
which one they're referring to uh but
what i want to point out here is that
yeah the objective is different so maybe
they say we can get by with this
objective
i don't see that that's a choice of the
modeler and you run into problems
with some environments if you don't have
a discount factor in any case
uh you can see right here in the
experiments for for example this is
atari
the decision transformer outperforms cql
in some respects uh it it trails it
in other ones i mean they also look at
like these standard deviations are
are quite high in the open ai gym
it is a bit it looks a bit better in
that
it sorry it does outperform cql
in quite a number of things and also
with
less standard deviation right here
yeah also they they they compare against
sort of behavior cloning where you
retroactively only train
on the um best such and such
percent of the experience and they find
that
if you hit the correct percentage which
is not necessarily the
only the best trajectories if you hit
the correct percentage sometimes
behavior cloning can actually give you a
better performance
however hitting that percentage of
course requires another hyper parameter
search and you as an oracle
you kind of have to you know you have to
go and filter and you have to try out
and and um you don't know you have to
have some sort of a validation set
whereas
the decision transformer is just one run
now throughout
all of this they're sort of touting that
they don't need
as many like searches and as many you
know like here
you need to choose that percentage you
need to figure it out
but if you look at their actual
configuration of hyper parameters down
here
they do things like well we have one
architecture
for these atari games but then we have a
different one for pong right
we have a context length for these atari
games but then a different one for pong
because pong is actually quite a sparse
rewardish
game okay compare these other ones so
they make
the context length bigger in order to
capture a longer history because
otherwise
they couldn't differentiate the agents
and they would need to use td
or some kind of dynamic programming
right and then there's also this this
how the return to go conditioning like
how much reward do you want to get
and that's a problem like so here again
they they do something and this is like
they look at
the baseline they look at cql how much
did that achieve
and then they just choose to achieve a
multiple
of that one they say it's like you look
at your competitor
at what you're compared to and then you
base your decisions
off of the result of that so
you know i i kind of get it and also
this multiplier they take
it is very informed by them knowing the
games right in pong
you know you can reach at max 21
so that's take a condition on the re
reward of 20 in in sequest it's
i think it's unbounded so they they do
it
1.5 times the performance of that
and yeah so
i'm not i'm like i'm not saying this is
invalid experiments but like
this this looking at your competitor and
then basing
crucial hyper parameters off of their
performance
but i'm sure i'm sure it will work
otherwise but just
know that you need to have a good idea
of what reward you can even achieve and
what's possible given your data set
right so cql also takes into account
like it also learns from the same data
set and that's sort of how they know
what's possible from that data set
uh yeah so is this a problem that you
need to know the ruler can't you just
put 100 billion billion billion
and the answer is no you see right here
this orange line is the highest reward
that was
observed in the data set now this is
is gamer normalized that's why it's not
like 21.
um but here the experiment it's actually
a pretty cool experiment
is since you're not only maximizing
reward you can
you can ask the model to to give you any
reward you want
so the green line is what you want it
and if the blue line
is what you achieved matches the green
line exactly the model
always gives you the actions to to make
that reward that you requested happen
okay and you can see that green line in
the blue line they match pretty
accurately
for a long stretch which meaning means
that this the sequence modeling approach
can
really not only give you the max reward
but it can give you sort of
any reward because it remembers all the
sequences
though probably not the lowest ones
because you're actually learning from a
dqn
learner that has probably only good
trajectories
okay but you can see as soon as you go
past
the highest observed reward
it not only does it stay flat it
actually drops down
again okay and you can see that pattern
pretty much anywhere where you have an
orange line like this so here
you well maybe you stay maybe you drop
down here it's that kind of seems like
you stay
it's only that here in the seaquest
where it's a bit better but like
this is a gamer normalized score of
three like a gamer would achieve
100 here um but you can also see that
sort of drop
compared to the green line so that means
you can't just put 100 billion
essentially so you need to know the
reward that you're going for
sometimes no problem sometimes actual
problem
okay and that reward is not only
dependent on the game
it is also depend on the game but it is
also dependent on
like how your data set is that you learn
from is structured you need to know what
your agent
can achieve they do some other ablations
with respect to context length they
actually find that
larger context length helps
so if you don't provide a long context
the performance drops
it makes sense in that the transformer
is able to match the history to observe
trajectories
better on the other hand a technically
reinforcement learning algorithm since
these
are in atari are fully observable if you
do frame stacking
you know technically an rl agent
shouldn't
uh shouldn't care about the more of the
past
but you know rl algorithms do they're
not perfect
um the last thing is that key to door
thing where they
show that okay there this is a an
experiment
uh toy setting by the way again
i did not find this in the appendix i
did not find code
for this so we actually we don't know
too much about this experiment but as
far as i understand
um there's one room there's two rooms
there's three rooms in the first room
there's a key
in the last room there's a door now
you're thrown into the first room you
get to walk around a bit then you're
thrown into the second room you get to
walk
for a variable length of time and then
you thrown into the last room
if you have put taken the key and
you you reach the door here then you get
a good reward
otherwise you fail okay so the middle
room is called a distractor
because if you have something like an
lstm or if you have something like
q learning or something so the the the
problem
with this uh sorry q
equals r plus q is that this
sort of looks one step ahead okay this
recurrence relation
that means if you have a learning signal
somewhere way down the line
you need to sort of propagate it's not
back prop it's actually
you need to learning step
propagate the fact that there is a
signal back here
all the way through these time steps in
the past where a transformer
can just go like boop okay so this is
this is an experiment designed to
show that this really helps so you can
see
right here they can analyze
what their system says about the
expected reward in the future so you can
always ask it
how probably is a given reward in the
future and you can see
whenever the agent doesn't pick up the
key it immediately knows
as soon as it gets into that second room
it immediately knows it's lost no matter
what happens in the last room
if it does pick up the key in these two
situations
it estimates a future reward of about
0.5 and you can see it does not degrade
across the distractor room okay so no no
matter how long the destructor room is
does not degrade um and that's the key
difference between this
and like let's say td learning uh q
learning approaches
it does not it doesn't forget
um because there is no dynamic
programming involved
and then you know in the last thing if
it reaches the door obviously it says
well that's a high value if it doesn't
reach the door
it changes its mind now i would have
liked to see
whether or not and this is why i was
keen on seeing the parameters of this
whether or not this right here is inside
or outside the context length of the
transformer they used
and i'm going to guess it's still inside
because as soon as that's outside or
like let's say more like this
as soon as that's outside the context
length the the
the system has no the sequence model has
no way of knowing
whether uh that particular agent picked
up the key
so it cannot predict anything i think
what they're
what they want to show right here sorry
that's an alarm
what they want to show right here is the
fact that the attention
weighs heavily on those frames where it
picks up the key or reaches the door
which is fine right we can we can get
that transformers learn that
however here i'd really you know like to
see what happens
if you go outside of that and again if
you go outside of that
you're going to revert back to the old
method so ultimately the transformer
gives you a longer context where you can
do
one step assignment of credit but again
as soon as you exceed that as with the
lstms as soon as you exceed these
you need the classic approaches and i
feel the paper is a little bit
is a little bit shady on the fact that
they get like a constant factor
longer context with what they're doing
but it doesn't really solve the problem
okay in my mind i might be wrong please
tell me
if i'm wrong read the paper for yourself
it is a good paper i hope we can cover
the trajectory transformer
in the future and with that i wish you
all the best bye-bye